well let me ask you uh
you mentioned dpt3 it's interesting to
ask
uh what are your thoughts about the
recently
released openai gbt3
model that i believe is already trying
to learn how to communicate
like grant sanderson you know i think i
got an email a day or two ago about
someone who wanted to um
try to use gpd3 with manum where you
would like give it
a high-level description of something
and then it'll like automatically create
the mathematical animation like trying
to put me out of a job here
i mean it probably won't put you out of
a job but it'll create something
visually beautiful for sure
i would be surprised if that worked as
stated but maybe there's like
variants of it like that you can get to
um
i mean like a lot of those demos it's
interesting i think
there's a lot of failed experiments like
depending on how you prime the thing
you're going to have a lot of failed i'm
certainly with code no program synthesis
most of it won't even run but eventually
i think if you
if you're if you pick the right examples
you'll be able to generate something
cool
and i think even that's good enough even
though if if it's
if you're being very selective it's
still cool that
something can be generated yeah that
that's huge value um
i mean think of the writing process
sometimes a big part of it is just
getting a bunch of stuff on the page and
then you can decide what to whittle down
to so
if it can be used in like a man machine
symbiosis where
it's just giving you a spew of potential
ideas that then you can refine down
like it's serving as the generator and
then the human serves as the refiner
that seems like a pretty powerful
dynamic yeah
have you uh have you gotten a chance to
see any of the demos like on twitter
is there a favorite you've seen or oh my
absolute favorite
yeah uh so tim blay who runs a channel
called acapella science he was
like tweeting a bunch about playing with
it um and
so he so gpt3 was trained on um the
internet
from before kovid so so in a sense it
doesn't know about the coronavirus
so what he seeded it with was just a
short description about like
a novel virus uh emerges in wuhan china
and starts to spread around the globe
what follows is a month by month
description of what happens january
colon
right that's what he sees it with so
then what gpt3 generates is like
january then a paragraph of description
february and such
and it's the funniest thing you'll ever
read because um it predicts a zombie
apocalypse
which of course it would because it's
trained on like the internet
zombie stories but what you see
unfolding is a description of
covet 19 if it were a zombie apocalypse
and like
the early aspects of it are kind of
shockingly in line with what's
reasonable
and then it gets out of hand so quickly
on the other flip side of that is uh
i wouldn't be surprised if it's on to
something at some point here
when you know 2020 has been full of
surprises
who knows like we might i'll be in like
this crazy militarized zone
as it predicts just a couple months off
you